do you remember me your mom's name was
Sarah
he used to our newspapers in your shoes
you're a wanted man
I don't do that anymore well the people
who think you did are coming right now
they're not planning on taking you alive
captain well a great many people see you
as a hero there are some would prefer
the word vigilante you've operated with
unlimited power and no supervision
that's something the world can no longer
tolerate I know how much Bucky means you
stay out of this one
please you only make this worse you
saying you'll arrest me
big consequences captain you seem a
little defensive buzz been a long day I
think except limitations we're no better
new bad guys that's not the way I see it
so simply want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I just want to make sure we consider all
our options just people that shoot at
you usually wind up shooting at me too
you know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this
what do we do we fight
sorry Tommy you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend
so was I
what happens if we do not unite our
world will perish this doesn't need to
happen
there is one